ein wirklich großes rätsel wurde
offenbar gelöst so genannte fast ray
burst fab also schnelle radiowellen
ausbrüche sind die wohl rätselhaftesten
ereignisse des universums dabei werden
bei diesem phänomen unbeschreiblich
gigantische energiemengen ins all
geschleudert und das innerhalb von
sekundenbruchteilen jetzt ist ein
australisches forschungsteam den
mysteriösen radio blitzen auf die spur
gekommen klick zum 2
hier gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
das was wir bisher über die so genannten
fast rangers fvb wissen hält sich
wirklich in grenzen
das fest steht die radio blitze sind
extrem stark und ultrakurz sie halten
nur millisekunden und entstehen wohl
außerhalb unserer galaxie
doch wie genau das ist unser bislang ist
es fachleuten lediglich gelungen die
quelle eines sich wiederholenden radio
boers zu identifizieren 2017 konnte so
das ereignis mit der bezeichnung f b 12
11 02 auf eine etwa drei milliarden
lichtjahre entfernte zwerggalaxien
zurückgeführt werden der ursprung ist
also extra galaktisch und die
radiosignale zeigten sich stark
polarisiert die experten und expertinnen
gehen aufgrund dessen davon aus dass das
entstehungs umfeld extrem magnetisiert
sein muss die analyse solcher
serientäter gestaltet sich
verständlicherweise deutlich einfacher
als die analyse von radio birds die nur
einmal kurz aufblitzen doch klar ist
auch dass letztere viel häufiger
vorkommen doch bislang gestaltete es
sich für forschungsteams weltweit als
unmögliche sache deren stelle
aufzustellen denn der puls ist schon
längst vorbei wenn eine ausreichende
anzahl an radioteleskopen auf empfang es
doch jetzt vermeldet einen astronomie
team aus australien einen sensationellen
erfolg die fachleute haben nämlich jetzt
erstmals den ursprung eines sich nicht
wiederholen radio berg ortet eine echte
premiere also dafür nutzen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
umkippen ist 35 radioantennen des
kilometer eric pathfinder in australien
das besondere laut studie dass er
erreicht eine maximale winkel auflösung
von 10 bogensekunden somit war es dann
auch möglich die herkunft eines radio
das zu orten der sich nicht wiederholt
der große durchbruch gelang im september
2018 der fas raiders mit der bezeichnung
fab 18 09 24 gegen dem forschungsteam
ins netz und das weil eben ein großer
bereich eine lange zeit beobachtet
werden konnte
darauf hatten die fachleute seit dem
jahr 2007 hingefiebert in diesem jahr
waren die fast railbirds nämlich
überhaupt erst entdeckt worden
die s bahn ist und seinen kolleginnen
und kollegen gelang es die quelle von
fhb 18 09 24 direkt und relativ genau zu
orten
das ergebnis zeigt dass auch die einzel
radio pulse extra galaktisch sind ebenso
wie die serientäter radio passt das
australische astronomie team konnte
zeigen dass die quelle von fab 18 09 24
auf einen rund 3,6 milliarden lichtjahre
entfernte galaxie zurückzuführen ist der
analyse zeigt aber auch dass es einen
wichtigen unterschied gibt zwischen dem
nun aufgespürten einzel puls und dem
2017 geordneten serientäter fab 12 11 02
zwar kommen beide aus einer fernen
galaxie doch zeigt sich die galaxie von
dem nun geordneten einzel radio passt
als inaktiv und massereich der serien
radio börse dagegen stammt aus einer
masse armen zwerggalaxien mit aktiver
sternen bildung und zahlreichen
gammastrahlenausbrüche und supernovae
und noch etwas ist anders der ursprungs
umgebung des nun aufgespürten einzel
radio blitzes fehlt es nach ansicht des
australischen forschungsteams wohl an
starken magnetfeldern die signale
stammen zudem wohl aus einem vorort der
galaxie das alles konnten die fachleute
durch die detaillierte auswertung der
datenlage herausfinden
die optischen teleskope von dieser
himmelsregion ermittelt hatten der
astronom deller der an der studie
beteiligt war fast das folgendermaßen
zusammen
durch winzige unterschiede in der
laufzeit von nur bruchteilen einer
milliarde für sekunde konnten sie sogar
seinen exakten ausgangsort ermitteln er
liegt rund 13.000 lichtjahre vom zentrum
dieser galaxie entfernt
das australische forschungsteam hat
durch seine entdeckung also gezeigt dass
sich die beiden bisher geordneten radio
börse in vielen faktoren unterscheiden
dazu heißt es in der studie die
unterschiede zwischen fh wien 18 924 und
eva b 12 02 deuten darauf hin dass es
zwei verschiedene populationen von radio
word urhebern geben könnte oder dass
diese urheber in sehr verschiedenen
umgebungen
trotz dieser spektakulären erkenntnisse
bleiben noch viele fragen offen die nur
durch weitere beobachtungen und analysen
geklärt werden können doch fest steht
dass ein tiefer gehendes verständnis
solcher radio blitze die astronomie
extrem nach vorne bringen könnte
denn forschungsteams weltweit arbeiten
daran diese mysteriösen phänomenen
langfristig gesehen auch als eine art
röntgengerät für den kosmos zu nutzen
die idee dahinter ist dass die signale
aufschluss darüber geben könnten welche
strahlung sie auf ihrem weg durch den
kosmos passiert haben apropos strahlung
ist 5g handystrahlung ungesund anklicken
das video anschauen und vor allem den
coolen kanal rating lepka bonn ihren bis
dann bleibt dran